lovely to meet you the film is
incredible and that comes from somebody
who's only been watching downton for the
last you know handful of years but the
thing that struck me the most about the
film is that it's got a very sort of
singing in the rain vibe obviously you
know all of the old hollywood and
bringing hollywood into downton but
particularly with this sort of subplot
with mary and mirna daglaish was that
film an influence sort of on this one at
all or were there any other early talky
or silent films that you've had in
there's a definite answer to that which
is that uh our producer gareth neems
grandfather ronald neem who is a very
famous director in his own right
uh bear with me on this when when he was
a young man was hitchcock's alfred
hitchcock's assistant on blackmail which
was the film shot in london in the late
20s that actually went from silent to a
talkie
and so
that was the influence on julian rather
than singing in the rain so it was
blackmail by hitchcock obviously you've
worked with julian fellowes before you
worked with him and elizabeth mcgovern
on the chaperone um but you've also
worked with you know a number of other
cast members from this film what was it
like sort of coming you've worked with
them before but what was it like sort of
coming in as a new director to a project
that they've essentially been i can
imagine that might be intimidating but
for me it was just a joy because to work
with a group of actors who'd been cast
as a family who now really were a family
who owned their characters so deeply
because they've been playing them for
over a decade
just made it a real pleasure actually
and obviously you are filming in these
these completely beautiful spaces you
know like this is it sort of
intimidating to take those characters
out of downton at all because they've
you know for you know most of the series
they've been in you know contained to
the one place was it sort of
yeah i think i think it was a relief for
everybody to get out of high clair yeah
it's a very particular house i mean very
beautiful in some ways but not easy to
film in and so when we got to france or
uh here uh rest park it was very
liberating
and this film even more so than you know
the first one of it or the series has
such a massive ensemble cast because
you're bringing in the family at the
villa and then the hollywood stars how
do you sort of balance making sure
especially all of the you know quote
unquote legacy characters get sort of
their due on camera
well again the script is a brilliant map
for that because uh julian is really
skillful at giving all his characters
satisfying journeys but my attitude was
to treat them all like film stars and
met them all beforehand and uh you know
the the legacy characters as you call
them or actors were
thrilled by the new arrivals and uh you
know hugh
dancy and
uh
dominick west and laura were you know a
joy to
add to the ensemble well that was all my
questions so thank you so much thank you
so much nice to meet you